[Music]
hello everyone so I just came up with
three warm-up exercises for the piano
and I'd like to mention just a few
things about how I came up with them and
why I did so generally speaking they're
all based around parallel intervals or
parallel triads instead of just
transposing them up chromatically I
found ways that I could dovetail each
chord or each interval into the next one
for example for the first one I'm using
both third fingers to shift up so that
it dovetails nicely into the next chord
for the second one instead of just going
up chromatically by major triads I added
a major sixth interval so that again it
dovetails nicely into the next one and I
added that little figure in the left
hand or the right hand depending on how
you're switching it up so that it sounds
a little more interesting for the third
one with the parallel thirds I used to
play it so that all the notes in the
left hand and the right hand are exactly
the same so instead of doing that I
switched it around so it just sounds a
little more crunchy I guess and it just
made it a little more interesting the
hands are closer together it adds a
little bit of confusion so that it makes
it the exercise a little more
interesting to me so one point in
general is that with all of these it
started with a very simple idea I wanted
to work on transposing this tried up and
down or transposing this figure up and
down but I tweaked them all a little bit
so that it's a a little more interesting
to play be a little more fluid from one
position to the next and three it sounds
a little more interesting than what I
had previously or what I could have
the
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
with all of these I think I could take
them even further and explore different
patterns different combinations to make
them all the more interesting all the
more fun to play
[Music]
and at the same time being functional as
a warm-up and as an exercise furthermore
I hope you can take little bits of ideas
from this and build your own warm-up
exercises I'll be creating some more
this was very very specific to parallel
intervals but I'll make some more with
arpeggios other chords and other
combinations so again thanks for
watching and I'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]